Move mistakes come in many forms. Sometimes
it's plot holes or continuity errors, other
times it's just poor judgement by the filmmakers.
When it comes to superhero movies, there's
a long history of questionable decisions that
have made us roll our eyes and throw popcorn
at the screen. So many in fact that we decided
to limit our list of facepalm inducing moments
to films based on DC properties.
Biggest Mistakes That DC Movies Have Made
So Far
Supermanturns back time
You can say it’s the superhero movie that
started it all. Richard Donner’s 1978 Superman
is a classic, establishing many of the tropes
that remain in this age of endless superhero
movies. However this is the only time, in
any version of the character, that Superman
has the ability to turn back time. In the
film’s climax, Superman must deal with two
nuclear missiles, only to discover that the
aftershock of one left Lois Lane dead. A devastated
Superman starts flying circles around the
earth so fast he manages to turn back time
and save Lois. This is a big power to establish
in one film and then never use again. Events
have less meaning when Superman can just undo
them anytime he feels like flying real fast,
but apparently Lois is the only one worth
busting this trick out for.
Batman and Robin-ALL the puns
The only thing the 1997 debacle that was Batman
& Robin accomplished was undoing everything
Tim Burton did to make the caped crusader
cool in 1989. Burton took the character
as far away from the campy 60s TV show as
he could, only for Warner Bros. and Joel Schumacher
to bring him right back, complete with bat
nipples, bat credit cards, and terrible, terrible
puns. One IMDb user counted no less that 27
ice puns used by Mr. Freeze alone. The movie
received such a frosty reception that they
froze production on the fifth Batman movie,
and waited 8 years for audiences to chill
out before relaunching with Batman Begins.
Catwoman-basketball scene
Catwoman was the first attempt to bring a
DC character back to the big screen since
the failure of Batman and Robin, and it didn’t
fare much better. From bad CGI to any excuse
to show of Halle Berry’s midsection, there
are almost too many cringe inducing moments
to choose from. The basketball scene, however,
is next level bad. What’s supposed to be
some fun flirtation over a game of one on
one between Catwoman and Benjamin Bratt’s
Detective character ends up looking more like
a 1990s Sunny D commercial. The dizzying camera
movements and quick cuts were presumably meant
to add to the scene’s playfulness but instead
add to the scene’s overall bizarreness.
Watchmen-Hallelujah
Zack Snyder’s extremely literal interpretation
of Watchmen is as divisive today as when it
came out in 2009. Love it or hate it, one
thing that almost everyone can agree on is
the misguided choice of putting Leonard Cohen’s
solemn voice singing Hallelujah over the sex
scene between Night Owl and Silk Spectre.
The song choice adds a whole new layer of
awkwardness to an already awkward sex scene.
It’s unclear what his intentions were here
and whether we’re supposed to take this
scene seriously or not. The real victims here
are the young people who see the film then
put Leonard Cohen on the next time they’re
trying to set the mood on a date.
Green Lantern-CGI suit
In 2011, as the Marvel Cinematic Universe
was ramping up towards the Avengers and Nolan’s
Dark Knight Trilogy was winding down, DC was
in need of another franchise, their attempt
came in the form of The Green Lantern. Unfortunately
it failed to meet expectations and the sequel
was scrapped. Some blamed this on the overuse
of CGI, particularly in regards to the Green
Lantern’s suit. One of the fun parts of
live action superhero movies is seeing their
costumes brought to life, but the Green Lantern’s
was just animated onto Ryan Reynolds, a fact
he makes a dig at in Deadpool when Wade Wilson
stipulates that his super suit can’t be
green… or animated.
Dark Knight Rises-where’s The Dark Knight?
When audiences go into a Batman movie there
are certain things they expect to see: cool
villains, a grimy Gotham city, the batmobile,
but above all, Batman! Bruce Wayne hung up
his cape in the previous film, so we knew
we’d have to wait for events to force him
to suit up again, and Nolan stretches that
anticipation for as long as possible, only
to have Batman defeated and start another
road to recovery. If you breakdown Batman’s
screen time, he’s only in about 30 minutes
of the movie, which is actually pretty close
to Batman’s screen time in the other films,
but when you consider that The Dark Knight
Rises is the longest Batman movie, running
2 hrs and 45 minutes, that’s a lot of time
spent without the story’s hero. Seriously,
I’ve seen bread rise faster than this Dark
Knight.
Man of Steel -Jonathan Kent’s Death Scene
Remember that scene in Austin Powers when
the security guard doesn’t get out of the
way of the slow moving steamroller? This is
what it felt like when watching Kevin Costner’s
death scene in Man of Steel. Sure the tornado
was moving faster than a steamroller, and
it was a powerful scene where Clark had to
choose not to use his powers to save his father,
but the way the scene was constructed it looks
like he doesn’t even try to save himself.
Perhaps Jonathan Kent had his own demons he
just wanted to escape. In Zack Snyder’s
dreary universe, this isn’t that far fetched.
Batman v Superman-Have we met?
When Batman and Superman meet in the comics
or animated films, they’re usually able
to deduce one another’s secret identities
rather quickly. For some reason they decided
not to take this route in Dawn of Justice
while also adding elements that made it even
less plausible. Batman is supposed to be the
world’s greatest detective, and in this
story he’s already been focussing on Superman
for two years when he meets Clark Kent, yet
even he’s unable to connect the dots. And
even though Kent is a journalist for a major
news corporation, he doesn’t have any clue
who billionaire Bruce Wayne is when he meets
him. Superman also apparently respects Batman’s
privacy by choosing not to use his X-ray vision
to look through Batman’s mask. If they knew
who each other were, they could have bonded
over having moms with same last name long
before almost killing each other.
DCEU-Too Little, Too Late?
One of the biggest issues with first two official
DCEU movies is that they feel very rushed.
With the failure of Superman Returns and the
Green Lantern, and the conclusion of the Dark
Knight trilogy, DC needed desperately to create
something that competed with with the MCU.
Superman was supposed to have a second standalone
film before introducing Batman, but after
the lukewarm reception Man of Steel got, they
needed to bring out the big guns. Even though
these first two films were mediocre at best,
there are already 11 more films in various
stages of development that will expand on
this universe. DC is really putting the cart
in front of the horse here in an obvious attempt
to catch up with what Marvel has achieved,
here’s hoping that rushed productions don’t
result in more DC disappointment.
These are just a few of the things that have
bugged us in DC’s movies over the years.
Were there any other choices they’ve made
you felt were a mistake? Let us know in the
comments and be sure to subscribe for more
vides like this.